so this weekend we have a movie starting
Jesus Christ himself and that movie is
non-stop
don't lie to yourself you know it's true
[Music]
non-stop so non-stop stars Liam Neeson
he plays a Marshall he's on an airplane
flying across the Atlantic and he gets a
text message on his super-secret clothes
Network cellphone and the text message
says someone on the flight is gonna die
every 20 minutes until this guy gets 150
million dollars and after that it's a
downward spiral of events for Liam
Neeson while he's trying to figure out
what's going on and then chaos starts
happening on the airplane because it's
an airplane and you have a list of
suspects honestly this movie starts out
you're going through the airport you see
people and you're like oh that guy looks
shady it's gonna be him that did shady
too it's gonna be him maybe it's the
little 7 year old girl who was afraid to
fly on the plane you don't know Liam
Neeson was good in the Robie he's always
good in these roles because he always
has fun with these roles honest to god
think he talks with his agent every
morning he's like any scripts on my desk
where I get to play an older badass yes
cool let's do that he's pretty badass
but in this movie he's kind of a dick
also he gets this dude in an arm holding
he's like could you point out who you
saw and he's dragging this guy all about
the cabin in this arm hole that's
clearly painful your life be a little
more diplomatic I feel like Liam Neeson
could have been like all right I really
need your help if you could point out
this guy you saw it would save lives can
you do that for me man if it gives you
put his face up against the glass
and be like I'm gonna blow that window
if you don't help me think about those
movies you look at the movie you're like
it's completely functional I am enjoying
the movie only thing is you have to
suspend your disbelief on a lot of
everything is so perfect in this movie
the premise is someone's gonna die every
20 minutes but it's not a tube it's not
like this guy is killing people it's
like things are set in motion and then
it happens to work out for the guys plan
that works for a script like the words
on paper that is a script because the
screenwriters are like watch we can
write a series of events that ends up
working out perfectly for the guy
because we're screenwriters that's what
we do this takes me out of it
because I'm like there's no way the
world would be that perfect for the guys
on the nose 20 minutes Liam Neeson's
watch starts beeping and someone is now
dead every step in between worked out
flawlessly with all these variables that
screwed up now like when things screwed
up in the movie they actually didn't
screw up they were working
the guy's plan I refuse to believe they
have queue from Star Trek The Next
Generation on this flight because that's
who could make it happen cute baby then
he'd be like it's not working it's too
hard it's just stupid grievously savage
child race so non-stop is not realistic
nothing makes sense it's cheesy but fun
enough to be kind of interesting well as
cheesy and enjoyable to watch all around
I will say non-stop is a good time no
alcohol required so your favorite Liam
Neeson movie of all time anything he's
done what is it whatever it be comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]